[Music]
monta Generoso in the swiss canton of
Ticino has a new landmark the fee
already petra which means stone flower
is perched at a lofty altitude of 1700
meters it's world-famous architect Mario
Botta has come to give his official
blessing to the octagonal restaurant
with its panoramic views the Swiss
architect was inspired by the form of
the mountain I wanted to do justice to
two different sides of the mountain one
of them which faces south is very pretty
the other is north facing and is craggy
and steep I could do that via this big
Terrace and in the building at its end
the stone flower grows out of the
geometry the topography of the mountain
construction work took almost two years
working at that gradient and altitude
was a big challenge tons of material
have to be transported by a helicopter
or funicular railway the building cost
almost 19 million euros you can eat
inside the fury de Petra and you can
drink in the scenery on the terrace
every last detail was designed by Mario
Botta the architect shows Greystone for
the external cladding designed to mirror
the mountain itself la Pietra portcullis
LED stone stands for the mountain
ketchup inside I like the thought that
architecture doesn't mean that a
building occupies a place instead the
building becomes a part of the place
Mario Botta grew up in Switzerland and
studied architecture in Italy in 1970 he
set up his own office over the years he
has worked on 800 projects all over the
world one of his most famous works is
the San Francisco Museum of Modern Art
which opened in 1995 bata is a master of
both geometric forms and likes to use
materials like stone and concrete as he
did in Tel Aviv's symbolist a synagogue
and Jewish heritage center typical of
his architectural handwriting the red
brick and round form of every Cathedral
in France only the noise tree become a
cup everyone writes his best fake-ass
picasso signature is unmistakable you
just need to see two single strokes
Garcia Marquez wrote a number of novels
but its language remained the same I
think that my style is very
autobiographical Mario Bottas monumental
architectural style has had the greatest
impact on his home canton of Ticino
where he's best known for his
ecclesiastical buildings the church of
san giovanni battista and the mountain
village of mono has striking black and
white stripes and attracts lots of
tourists
whatuh hopes that the florida pietre
will be just as popular it's a project
that's particularly close to the
architects heart after all he grew up
near Monticello so and frequently
enjoyed its panoramic views over the
border to Italy da bomb be know as a
child the mountain was the world for me
the peaks the out the entire universe
solely I climbed up the mountain in the
early morning to see the sunrise this
mountain let me see the world in morning
on April 8th the funicular railway will
start to carry visitors up the
mountainside to the new building that's
when Mario Botta see already Petra opens
its doors to the public the new landmark
certainly faces stiff competition the
panoramic views from Monticello Rosso
[Music]